I'm excited to talk about today's topic.
What do we get to talk about?
We're going to talk about how do you find the right workflow for you.
I think that's a thing that's really hard for you.
You're like, okay, I'm going to do image analysis.
Where do I start?
I guess I'll just take a software and just mash on it until something comes out.
That's a thing you can totally do, but that often ends up feeling really stressful.
Yeah.
You mean you don't always have to start everything from scratch?
No.
In fact, you do not.
There's a lot of dimensions to the right workflow.
You can think about is this in the tool that you want to use?
First of all, of course, is it giving you accurate results?
If it's not giving you accurate results, then you know.
It is perfectly okay to see something that somebody else has published and decide that's
not what I want to do.
What I would rather do is adopt something else that wasn't really published for my system.
I wanted to just talk about some of the resources that are out there in terms of being able
to actually find the right workflow for you.
Knowing how to find workflows, then if you know how to find several of them, you can
figure out, well, this one is in the best tool for me because it matches the programming
language I'm already using or things like that, or because I already know somebody who's
good at that and I can go down the hall and ask them.
If you can find multiple potential places to start, then you can find the best place
to start.
The first one, and it seems kind of obvious, but just, you know, is PubMed.
It is completely reasonable and we talk to people all the time to just say, what do people
in my field do already?
Generally speaking, there are no cookies for reinventing the wheel.
If there's already a great thing in your field for, you know, say you study, I feel
like this is always my example, but it's just a protein that I like and there's a lot of
study like H2IX.
I can look at recent papers in my field that if I search H2IX and then maybe add microscopy
if there's a ton of results, which here there are a ton of results.
Currently, the people, especially recently are being asked to share their image analysis
workflows and are not just saying images were analyzed in an image check.
But if you have colleagues who are publishing in your system, talk to them, see what they
do.
You don't have to do exactly what the colleagues in your field do.
You might be able to figure out something better than what's currently the state of
the art or the state of the field.
But absolutely start by just seeing, you know, okay, this person says that they have a cell
profiler pipeline that I can use or they've made actually a whole Nepari plug-in that's
exactly for, you know, counting yeast cells, things like that.
Absolutely great.
If that works for you and it seems to produce great results, you know, since you're going
to be reading these papers anyway, nothing wrong with going to the methods section first
and seeing hopefully that there is a good method section that gets you exactly what
you need.
If that doesn't work out for you for one reason or another, either it doesn't work or you
do just want to sort of cast a wider net.
One thing I think is important to note and we've noted it in previous episodes, so this
is actually our blog post from our example forum post from our episode on how to make
great forum post.
Certainly one thing you can do is sort of look for people who study your biology do.
But the second that you're not doing that anymore, you can expand to far beyond your
biology and it won't change your image analysis much.
So again, we talked about this in the forum episode that saying to people, I study H2AX
and it's normal in DNA damage.
Because anyone who has a workflow for studying H2AX will hopefully maybe get you what you
want but that it's actually, you know, from an image analysis standpoint just as good
if not better to say, hi, I have nuclei and small dots that sit inside the nucleus, can
anybody help me with that?
Because the number of people who study things that make dots is bigger than the number of
people who study H2AX specifically and their workflows might totally work for you.
So not getting too constrained by your biology, you know, is a really important thing for
when you want to find somebody else's workflow to adopt to be your own.
Some ideas for resources.
Obviously, the thing we know best is CellProfiler and CellProfiler has examples pages
and tutorial pages that all start with, here's a picture of the thing that's segmented.
And so if you are a bacterial colony researcher, this yeast colony thing, again, it's a different
species but if the dots are about the right size and about the right pattern and your
stuff is bright field microscopy, this will probably work for you.
It might need some tuning but it will work better for you than, you know, something that
was bacterial specific but meant for fluorescence, you know, not in a dish.
And the things go from like, here's a mouse lung to here are yeast plates to tissue to
wound healing and bright field to C. elegans, tons of different starting places.
And hopefully one of them looks kind of like where you need to start from.
It might not be the exact same biology but you can sort of ignore the biology and just
look at the image and think about the properties we talked about.
And the same thing for our tutorials page, you can sort of scroll through and see are
any of these, you know, kind of similar to things you need to identify.
Yeah, and so the difference between, as we say, the difference between our examples
and our tutorials.
The examples, so the tutorials are much, have a lot of extra content in there.
You can see, you know, download the materials.
So like here we have lots of extra information actually stepping you through every single
module so you understand what does every single module do?
Why is it in the pipeline?
You know, really fully understand all the moving pieces end to end.
Whereas examples are much more, here's a pipeline.
It does the thing.
Yeah, great point.
And maybe if you're lucky for a CellProfiler, like you will find somebody who has published
a pipeline that is sort of similar to something that you've done.
And we, you are always welcome if you publish a CellProfiler pipeline in a paper to contact
us and we will put it on our website and people can find your work well.
Yeah, this is certainly not comprehensive in terms of what is out there.
So help us make it better.
Let us know.
You have something you want to join.
But not only CellProfiler.
So Napari has a gallery and so you can look and see, okay, these are some things for 3D.
These are some things for, you know, photograph type objects where they're bright and dark.
You know, here's things where we're looking for points and so you can look through the gallery on those.
A lot of soft version will describe things as a gallery, which is not necessarily what
we're used to thinking about.
But you can see one in, for example, the bio image archive where they also have galleries
where you can sort of browse through and these are for data sets, but you can follow the data set to a paper
because this only takes data that's associated with papers and hopefully, again, the paper will have its workflow.
One thing that's fun that just came out is the folks at SSBD.
The Riken Institute in Japan put out an image similarity search that you can search by the text of what you're searching for
or you can upload a sort of small picture and have it say, give me pictures that look like this.
Again, this is going to get you data, not a workflow, but hopefully some of these data sets have workflows associated with them
and they'll help you sort of figure out beyond your biology where you might find things.
And the last and I think always most important, image.sc, you can either sort of search if,
so here I'm just looking at the image analysis category and just in the past month or so,
people who want things for FRAP, people who want things with RGB, people who want things for fibers,
all kinds of things like cytological smears, like all kinds of things.
But you can also just, as we talked about in our forum episode, post something like,
here are my images, here are my dots and let experts sort of say,
oh, I've worked on something like that before, it's totally different biology to yours.
And here's how you do it.
Love it. Those are some great examples.
Yeah. So there's lots of resources out there. You shouldn't have to start from scratch
unless you really, if you want to start from scratch and learn, be our guest.
Thanks, Beth. Thanks. See you later. Bye.